this film I like it another thor
ragnarok so I have just gotten out of
the theater from seeing this third entry
in the Thor franchise I some teen entry
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe overall
and I had a pretty darn good time with
this one I'm gonna get into spoilers
pretty much right off the bat because I
mean I think if you really cared about a
spoiler free review you'd be getting
those from you know people who actually
get to go to press screenings and had
their reviews out like a week ago so if
you're here for me you probably want my
full opinion at least that's what I'm
hoping so
spoilers will follow pretty quickly but
then again a lot of what I'm gonna talk
about has apparently already been in the
marketing exactly to what degree I don't
know cuz I cut myself off from the
marketing after the first trailer where
where it showed that the Hulk was gonna
be there I haven't watched any of it
beyond that but in any case all the
performances are good across the board
returning new Tessa Thompson as the
Valkyrie ho oh she's so good there's so
much I love about this character it's
funny I thought about it I'm like I
can't think because the the sort of
drunken but competent
jaded warrior thing is not exactly new
it's it's a fairly well worn it's not
quite so cliches to be you know overdone
but it's not new ground except I can't
think of a time it's been done with a
female character and she nailed it like
she was so good in that and I love that
they did not push any kind of romantic
angle it was just yeah that was real
good so she would she was the highlight
for the new cast of oh all the new major
cast was good I can't Blanche and she is
able to exude a great just presence I
mean it's wide gladder is why she worked
really well as Galadriel in Lord of the
Rings despite not appearing very much in
this she just she shows up on screen and
she just kind of owns the screen and
given that hella kind of only appears
sporadically across the movie she kind
of needed to be able to do that and she
can she's good
that Jeff Goldblum is just at his Jeff
Goldblum iist
and it's fun and it it was a really good
pick to put him in that kind of role
because the the grandmaster is kind of a
villain like for just a middle chunk of
the movie but you didn't need him to be
like legitimately intimidating or
anything because you had hella for that
so to have him it feel a very different
function and have a different feel from
the other villain of the thing was a
nice spec that went really well you know
the the side characters the other
gladiators they were fun I liked them I
suppose the only one that was maybe
wasn't the the highlight but you know it
was good was Karl Urban as scourge the
scourge was fine although I'm gonna
gotta bring up scourge and there's got
to be kind of my first major spoiler it
annoys me that scourge got this sort of
redemption and big hero moment to die in
in the same movie that two-thirds of the
warriors three were killed
incredibly offhandedly like on premise
that annoys me and I know that the
Warriors three have not been a massive
part of these films but they've still
been in all three of the Thor movies and
whichever one sort of kind of got the
shaft in the second one he got a bit of
a highlight here I almost feel like that
was the filmmakers doing paying penance
but the the the the hefty I can't
remember these characters names off atop
my head and I'm not gonna stop this to
look it up but the swashbuckling guy and
the hefty guy they just get they just
get killed like that
and I I'm not overly attached to them as
characters but when they've been in
three films and they haven't been
dragging down three films they've been
positive elements in in the previous two
films to kill them that haphazardly Ike
I have a problem with that it's not that
dissimilar to them killing off Cyclops
in the third x-men film and I don't like
it because even if you've decided that
these characters should die or if as a
filmmaker you're like I don't need these
guys let's just get rid of them when
you're dealing with characters who have
a
geared in more than one film in this
series and and again it's not like jar
jar binks it's not like everyone was
going like somebody that was their
favorite secondary character for
somebody that swash buckling guy was
their favorite secondary character for
somebody that guy who just loved to eat
was their favorite secondary character
and I just I don't think it would have
been that much work just to give them
slightly more notice than that and I
know I know how nitpicky this is in the
scheme of the movie but he really it
really didn't get under my skin a little
bit I didn't like the callousness and
it's it's the same issue with just
callously shooting Jimmy Olsen and
Batman V Superman or the the ultimate
cut but yeah is that that's somebody's
favorite character could you could you
show a little more respect than that but
moving on from that the the plot what
worked it was good but it was very kind
of chunky you could really divide it up
into pieces so it's like here's the main
plot dealing with saving Asgard and that
basically gets put in the background
while we deal with this entire side plot
on Sekar and it is a bit just
structurally it's a little bit yea wonky
but I love I like putting Thor into that
kind of environment I found that really
fun I thought all the stuff on Sircar
was good and hope hope was great I mean
I don't I never doubted that Hulk was
gonna be great but and I loved it like
how just sort of the chummy vibe yeah I
going with Valkyrie that was terrific
and she's with her and bitter she's like
I feel like I know you I did and that
was good there's a ton of great little
touches like that across the whole movie
what you're supposed brings me to the
tone overall this is a fairly jokey
movie I'm not sure whether I would
consider this more or less jokey than
the guardians of the galaxy films
I think slightly less in my estimation
but here's the thing it and I know some
people the lighter tone the jokey er
tone of these
these bothers them and they don't like
that and that's a matter of personal
taste but here's what I would say they
tried to go really serious really oh god
this is the other stakes oh my god
everything's like oh the world's coming
to an they went for that tone and Thor
the dark world and I think Thor the dark
world is one of the most forgettable
films in all of the MCU universe I mean
it's not bad it's not a bad movie but I
remember almost nothing about it and
more to the point they would still try
and have moments of levity but some of
them read what I think of the moments of
levity that landed with a clunk and fell
out of place I tend to think of Thor the
dark world where as this I feel that
with most of the Marvel stuff they do
better when they have a lighter feel but
go for deeper emotion which this does it
a few points you know has some darker
things you wanna have some states you
feel the weight of some stuff or Gardens
the galaxy 2 is another good example
where they really got some good you know
emotional stuff out of that I think they
do that better than being serious and
trying to add light elements to that
because that's one would get stuff like
Thor the dark world where it doesn't it
doesn't feel as right injecting humor
into a situation that dire can work I'm
not saying it can't but I don't think
the Marvel machine processes that as
well as adding drama or and stakes to a
more lighthearted feel I feel like that
just works much better in the universe
that they build in the kinds of films
they tend to make so I think that this
works on that level for some people is
it gonna be overly jokey probably maybe
for me it still works because for me
none of the jokes
feel it doesn't feel crowbarred in none
of them feel inserted because we needed
a joke here they're pretty much at least
all the ones that I am remembering
thinking back on it are rooted in
character
they feel true to how these characters
would speak would act
settar and therefore it feels fine
because to me comedy it feels the most
forced when it doesn't come organically
to the situation or the characters
that's what it feels crowbar din that's
where it feels like they had a serious
scene sounds like we should have a joke
there and they just plug a joke in and
that is where it tends to not work so
well but I don't get that feel from the
humor in this it feels all very rooted
in the situation and the characters and
how they react to the situations that
they're in so for me the the humor
worked well and never felt detracting
from the whole thing I think I think
that's about it overall like I said I
had a lot of fun in my major criticism
is again I will admit a very very very
nitpicky one but I I like I like the
feel of it I like the vibe of it I like
the the high the high stakes but that we
never we never missed just great
interactions with characters and the
stakes did feel legitimate I mean hell
it did feel like a very serious
legitimate threat to all of this and
like I said Cate Blanchett's presence
really put it over the top anchor and
the other thing is Chris Hemsworth he's
good at comedy so leaning into the
comedic aspects of him as a character or
putting him in situations that allow him
to have more of those comedic moments
you know being overly blustery or you
know trying to act on top of it when
maybe he's not it it works really well
and he's really good at that so I think
I think about wraps it up I mean again
overall really positive I don't know
where it would follow my overall rank of
the MCU as a whole but it is pretty
cleanly my favorite Thor film in that
particular sub franchise so I think that
about wraps this one up thor ragnarok
have you seen it what you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on iTunes and stitcher I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast that is a presentation of the
fire and water podcast network fire and
water podcast
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]